hi I'm cam Johnson
today I'm kicking with Bleacher Report
and tiso cab when you heard about the
train what was your mindset what did you
think I quickly when I got here was able
to meet the people with the Nets and and
get acclimated with them and get
acclimated with Brooklyn as best as I
could in a short amount of time
everybody kind of has somebody different
they can really point to as somebody
that helped them along help them get to
whatever point that they got to having
it in your father is just so special
because that's a relationship that lasts
a lifetime and something that's always
going to be there for you thank you for
everything that you've done for me and
for my brothers on behalf of myself
please report in tiso I'd like to give
you this tiso super sport watch
ah thanks buddy this is nice didn't
expect this I really thank you I like
this one I like this yeah I like this I
like the band The Black yeah that's nice
[Music]